this is the scene from hyde park
[Music]
they don't have anything in the garden
oh
in through
to count exactly 82.
now this has to be complete by
a minute
to 1 o'clock because at that point we
will see the skies fill with aircraft
heathrow will have been closed
in order to see the waves
come across of the aircraft
[Music]
so these are the guns that we saw
marching past the queen earlier on
today at the end of
the queen's birthday parade
[Applause]
meanwhile right outside buckingham
palace
is building steadily
[Music]
it seems a great sea of people coming
down
from the far end of the mall these are
people who have waited patiently in
order to wish the queen a very happy
classroom jubilee there's some cheering
behind me
and i'm sure that's only going to get
louder
but meanwhile the guns are firing
and they're also doing so in other parts
of the united kingdom
belfast cardiff colchester
in edinburgh where my own castle i'm the
governor there
105 regiment royal artillery will be
firing a 42-gun salute
in gibraltar and stonehenge
and
plymouth
and that's this naval base there
portsmouth 2
sterling
york museum and on board ship hms prince
of wales will be firing hms portland hms
kent
first two of those ships the first in
south of plymouth at sea and the other
at anchor of torbay and finally ships
alongside in foreign ports
in stockholm hms defender
and hms montrose
in bahrain
the commanding officer of the king
street royal horse artillery who is
major fran psych she must be immensely
proud of the preparation made by 170 of
her personnel and there were 120 horses
on parade
but my goodness look at the multitude
coming down the mall
a wonderful sight indeed
so these guns that
new action in the first world war
between 1914 and 18
and yet are so beautifully cared for and
looked after the crimes getting
more and more excited as they get closer
and closer to the palace meanwhile
inside the queen and other members of
the royal family will be watching
coverage of this
as they all reassemble after returning
from horse guards
as i was saying the front of buckingham
palace is a building site at the moment
and that's why all the windows are
blocked off with blue coverings because
inside enormous amounts of work are
being done but there has been a special
route
made through the building site for the
queen and working members of the royal
family to reach the balcony
in a few minutes time
[Applause]
here she comes
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
the queen looked down from this balcony
with her father at the end of the second
world war in 1945.
she looked down at the end of her
coronation in 1953
69 years ago today but here after 70
years as our sovereign the queen with
the working members of her family who
support her in her role
she's getting a huge happy birthday
[Applause]
[Applause]
the guns will go on firing for another
two minutes
and then
the sky will be filled with the noise of
aircraft past and present
to salute her majesty from the royal air
force and from the battle of britain
historic memorial
flight is holding a stick that was given
to her by the army as a present for her
platinum jubilee
as the first wave
with a wildcat helicopter
which is escorted here by two merlin
helicopters these
aircraft that know
the capabilities that they have in time
of battle
and you can see the waves coming
the next
wave two another wild cat with three
apache helicopters
very shortly the royal family will see
above
the great golden symbol of victory
those
aircraft heading towards them
i can certainly hear them myself
[Applause]
[Music]
so from the royal navy that first wave
from
world naval air station yeovilton will
be shortly above us
as the guns
complete their firing
[Music]
it's always very difficult to assess
quite how high these aircraft are but
i'll tell you they are as low as they
are allowed and
they can see the queen's eyes from where
they're sitting in their
cockpits to see from each aircraft
and overcomes the first wave
[Music]
wave two which is one british army
wildcat with three british army apaches
coming from
royal naval air station at yogelson and
also a watershed flying school
and wave three
one wild heck
helicopter with three merlin helicopters
again
and then wave four three puma
helicopters and three massive sinhooks
there's a really deep down draft and
rumble as they go over here and it's
fantastic but look perhaps one of the
greatest sites of all from the battle of
britain flight coming towards us now and
for the queen and her generation as they
see this great lancaster bomber flanked
by three spitfires and two hurricanes
what a great sight
i think two spitfires maybe one of them
wasn't up to snuff this morning but look
at them flying over now
the raw listen to it brings back
memories of 1939-45
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and you can tell she remembers that roar
from those memories of her childhood
when london faced the blitz and danger
was everywhere and yet overcome and at
greater speed now
one venom and four texans roar across
wave 7 and the workhorse of the royal
air force which has helped deploy troops
to challenges all over the world
supporting the royal navy the royal air
force and also the army and its tasks
three hercules
we'll hear their raw
then
in wave eight lofty and trenchant in the
sight that they give us all here in
london a massive atlas
and globemaster c-17
again these great workhorses that have
played their part in supporting the
armed forces
[Music]
i'm sorry if i'm getting excited but the
sound of that roar is so fantastic and i
remember it from times i've needed to
see those aircraft in the sky when
deployed
and wave nine a poseidon
and a rivet joint
these aircraft that keep us safe
they listen they look and they make sure
that we know where danger lies
[Music]
i think the queen's loving it as much as
we are
as she has seen so many of these
aircraft particularly when she's visited
military organizations throughout her
reign
wave 10 is a voyager a lightning and a
typhoon and remember all these aircraft
have to be timed at different stages
[Applause]
[Music]
supporting it
[Music]
as each of them lifts away and makes its
way towards
the airflow
system that it needs to get into to get
out of the
the way air force vip voyager vespina
with four lightnings
i think the
bird life of london's all flown away i
saw them leave after the first wave it's
a marvelous
roar of each of them coming over wave 12
is four hawks
attack aircraft
i think young lewis find that quite
noisy
and here we are at 7-0
wave 13-15 typhoon making the mark of
the queen's 70 years of sovereignty
[Applause]
[Music]
and here they come the red arrows in red
white and blue filling the sky with the
great salute of the three national
colors
the queen platinum jubilee
commander in chief
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
anthem for her majesty from
the new guard and the old guard who are
in the process of handing over the new
guard we saw troop the color earlier on
for the irish grass the queen
leaving
[Applause]
the duke of kent and the earl of wessex
the last to leave of the royal family
as
the pages close the windows and that
balcony appearance is done
that really was
rather special wasn't it aleister i
think the only person that matched your
enthusiasm and excitement was little
prince louis
you know
what one sees there is a salute to the
queen but they're working aircraft yeah
that if you're a soldier on the ground
or you're out at sea and you need help
when you see those come over you know
you're safe and it's a sign i think of
the protection and the importance of
protecting the kingdom and where the
queen forms the leadership role in that
it has effect and it matters to soldiers
sailors and men and women